Japan is a land of tradition. It's a country where
ancient customs are revered. But Japan also has
a long history of embracing cutting-edge
ideas and technologies. Like toilets that
shoot water directly at your scrotum and
vending machines that sell… well, yeah.
That's a bit of a contradiction, isn't it? How
can a country that's so deeply rooted in tradition
be one of the most technologically advanced on
earth? Well, the truth is that Japan's evolution
from a feudal society, as recently as the 19th
century, to a global economic powerhouse come
the 20th century, is actually one of the
most remarkable stories in human history.
If you need an example of how eagerly
Japan can embrace a technology when it
wants to - look no further than the digital
camera, although an American invention,
Japan quickly “snap”-ped it up and monopolised the
market the likes of which I don’t think I’ve seen
in any other consumer tech product.
Sony - Japanese, Canon - Japanese,
Nikon - Japanese, Fujifilm - Japanese,
Panasonic - Japanese, Olympus - Japanese,
Pentax - Japanese. Anyway, you get the picture
- sorry. Although, arguably Japan’s technologic
export game peaked in 1958 when they invented
instant ramen. Oodles of noodles, in a cup,
in an instant … screw the digital camera, that’s
the pinnacle of human achievement right there.
And all this from Japan. A country that only
opened its doors to the outside world in 1853,
at about the same time steam trains were first
gaining traction in Britain. Just a quick warning
that this is going to be a difficult video for me,
it’s all about a technology that we invented then
decided to be so crap at it come the 21st century
that almost everyone else now does it better.
Anyway, what was it that suddenly catapulted
the tiny island nation of Japan from a feudal
society to a technological superpower, seemingly
overnight? The answer is simple: a revolution. A
revolution catalysed by a single technology
that changed everything. A technology that,
in the space of a few decades, broke
down seemingly insurmountable barriers
and connected what were previously out-of-reach
intellectual minds and financial hubs. The result?
Japan exploded, humbly making a mockery
of the rest of the world in the process.
This is the fascinating story of the
Shinkansen - the Japanese bullet train.
The opening of Japan's first railway line in
1872 represented a welcome sign of progress,
but the trains were slow and unreliable,
and the steam engine frequently broke down,
leaving passengers stranded for hours at a time.
As Japan grew in the first half of the 20th
century, more and more railway lines were
built. But the issues that plagued the first
trains stuck around. By the 1950s, the average
speed of a Japanese train was a paltry 36 miles
an hour, and it wasn't uncommon for a trip from
Tokyo to Osaka - a distance of just 300 miles - to
take over 7 hours. And the infrastructure made no
sense either - tracks often followed the winding
course of rivers rather than the shortest distance
between two cities, meaning trains were constantly
slowing down to weave their way around bends.
By this point, the first cars and
aeroplanes had already arrived in Japan,
and overnight the populace came to favour
them over sluggish trains. However, in 1958,
the country was preparing to host the Olympic
games and Japan was keen to show the world
that it had evolved significantly since the
end of the Second World War and was now a
modern nation capable of hosting the most
prestigious sporting event on the planet.
But their embarrassing rail system didn’t
exactly shout “progress”, so in 1959,
the Japanese government solidified plans for the
first ever high-speed railway line. The project
would cost more than Jeff Bezos’ divorce
- actually nothing costs that much - but
at an estimated $200 billion Yen (about £1
billion), it would be pricey. However the
government was willing to spend big. This was
about more than just getting people from A to
B - this was a statement - a reaffirmation to
the world that, yes, Japan had been defeated,
but was now ready to rise again from the ashes
as a phoenix, a sexy metal train-shaped phoenix.
But to pull this off the Shinkansen engineers
would have to innovate in quite a few ways.
For a start, unlike other train systems, which
often shared tracks with slower local trains,
the Shinkansen would operate on its own
dedicated routes. Moreover, these tracks
were engineered with banked turns, allowing the
train to maintain its blistering speeds even
through curves. They weren't building a railway,
they were building a Goddamn rollercoaster.
To enhance the smoothness of the ride, the
tracks employed continuous welded rails.
Traditionally tracks were short segments bolted
together, which incidentally is the primary cause
of the all-too-familiar "click-clack" noise. The
Shinkansen's seamless tracks meant less friction,
which meant higher speeds and less maintenance.
And when your entire country is prone to sporadic
Godzilla attacks, having to fix stuff less often
is a Godsend. To ensure the Shinkansen would be
stable at such high speeds it was necessary
for the existing Cape Gauge tracks (at 3ft 6
inches wide) to be beefed up to what we now call
“Standard” Gauge (at a girthy 4 ft 8.5 inches).
Level crossings were eliminated too
- bridges were utilised frequently
along the routes so cars don’t have to
slow down for trains and vice-versa.
Rather than coil springs the Shinkansen used a
revolutionary air-spring suspension system to
increase comfort and stability. And, of course,
the Shinkansen was given an iconically massive
pointy nose. It looked like pure science-fiction
in the 60s, and it was a hallmark of aerodynamic
design, meticulously crafted to minimise
air resistance and to suppress “tunnel
boom” - the loud booming noise created when
a train enters a tunnel at high velocity.
They even created a special diagnostics train,
nicknamed “Doctor Yellow” - this bright yellow
rolling stock is equipped with special sensors
to monitor the condition of the tracks
below and the overhead wires. All so that
faults in the network can be detected
as quickly and efficiently as possible.
And all these efforts paid off.
The fastest steam train in Japan
at the time topped out at 60 mph, and
the first Shinkansen railway - now
known as the Tokaido line - had a top
speed of 130 mph, more than double.
That may not sound particularly fast by today's
standards, but it was a game changer for the
people of Japan. It slashed the average journey
time from Tokyo to Osaka to just 4 hours. We've
got a train that takes longer than that in
England and it only goes to fucking Wigan.
Then in 1975 the Sanyo Shinkansen extension
line was built, connecting Tokyo all the way to
Fukuoka - you could now go from Fucking Fukuoka to
Tokyo - a distance of 680 miles, in just 5 hours,
without changing trains - the people of
Fukuoka thought this was Fuckoak-ing brilliant.
The success of the Shinkansen wasn't just due
to the massive reduction in journey times. They
were also remarkably reliable - something that
couldn't be said for their conventional cousins.
A railway line is like a choose your own adventure
book - every few miles there's a point where the
trains can go one way or the other. And, just
like in a choose your own adventure book,
making the wrong choice can be the
difference between getting to work on
time or ending up naked in a swamp with
your ear being mauled by a horny otter.
If a train passes a junction and follows the
wrong track, the driver can't simply pull a
U-turn. The train will have to keep going until
it reaches the next station, at which point it can
change tracks and go back the way it came. These
“schedule deviations” can add hours to a journey.
In order to avoid schedule deviations, which
were plaguing conventional train lines,
the Shinkansen were equipped with an automated
system called Centralised Traffic Control
that allowed them to seamlessly navigate
even the most complex junctions without
having to slow down. Together with
a second automated safety system,
called Automatic Train Control (ATC),
also developed for the Shinkansen,
the system could automatically slow down any
train on the network depending on the speed of
the trains ahead or behind it and intervene if
a driver fails to respond to hazards in time.
Contrary to popular belief, the original
Shinkansen trains never actually levitated. That
requires something called maglev technology, which
has only been employed in real-life sporadically
over the years, usually for very short journeys,
like airport shuttles. Most notably the Shanghai
maglev was opened in 2004, offering top speeds
of 270 mph. Although the Shanghai maglev is
completely bloody useless - it only covers a
distance of 19 miles, over 7 and a half minutes,
which means by the time it reaches full speed
in the middle of its journey, it has to start
slowing down again. As a result it averages
a speed of 155 mph, slower than a non-maglev
high-speed train. I guess this is what happens
when a country has too much disposable income.
Despite not levitating, the original Shinkansen
trains were designed specifically to minimise
friction and vibration in every way. So they
could glide along the tracks like Usain Bolt
with a greased up arse. Even though the trains
were travelling at 130 mph, you could balance
a coin on its edge and it wouldn't fall over.
Passengers could place cups of tea on the window
ledges in the knowledge they wouldn't spill.
This might seem rather mundane to us today,
but back in the 60s, it was as if the
laws of physics had been rewritten.
Construction of the Shinkansen network was rapid.
Now there are 9 individual but interconnected
shinkansen lines, and counting. Connecting the
entire country, all the way from Sapporo in the
North, to Kagoshima in the South. With the fastest
train in Japan now cruising at a speedy 200 mph.
Today, the average delay for a
Shinkansen train is less than one minute,
and that includes delays caused by natural
disasters! To put that in perspective,
a British train being delayed by less
than one minute is rarer than seeing a
unicorn shitting gold coins, inside
a Wetherspoons. And that’s because
our trains are so old that the tracks are
made from the bones of Victorian children.
Speaking of natural disasters - Shinkansen
lines are fitted with earthquake detection
systems which can automatically cut
power to trains if early warning
signs are detected of a potentially dangerous
earthquake. Which is nice to know, I guess.
The implications of the Shinkansen
went beyond convenience. Economically,
cities that were connected by the Shinkansen
experienced unprecedented growth, from Osaka
to Nagoya to Hiroshima. It was like a game
of Monopoly where everyone wins and you don’t
spend four hours threatening to murder
your family for not selling you Mayfair.
Furthermore, the Shinkansen revolutionised the way
people lived and worked. Families no longer had
to be uprooted for job opportunities. Someone
could work in Tokyo but choose to live in a
quieter city like Shizuoka and commute daily. Such
a concept was unthinkable before the Shinkansen.
But the effects rippled around the globe.
Japan took a billion-pound-gamble and
pretty much placed it all on a single
train system. And boy did it pay off,
transforming it from a broken post-war economy to
being the third richest country on the freaking
planet. And that’s enough to make all the other
countries stand up and take notice. The Shinkansen
success story inspired the construction of similar
high-speed rail systems like the TGV in France,
the AVE in Spain, Germany’s ICE and many
more three-letter-acronym-inclined-nations.
But it can be argued that none have managed to
emulate the success of the Shinkansen. You see,
there are now faster trains out there.
But speed was never the primary goal
of Shinkansen’s design - it was capacity.
It was designed to move large numbers of
people quickly - this is a country with 125
million people and the world’s largest city.
And today during peak times a high speed
train departs from Tokyo every 3 minutes.
Every single day about a quarter of a million
people ride the Shinkansen in Japan. Also,
after 50 years of operation and over 10
billion passengers, the Shinkansen has
never had a single fatal accident - officially
making it the world’s safest train system.
And now, Japan is looking to the future, as
they always have done. New lines are being
developed using superconducting maglev technology
- like in Shanghai - which promises speeds of up
to 310 mph. When complete the Chūō Shinkansen
will be the longest maglev route in the world,
and a trip from Tokyo to Osaka will
take a breathtaking 67 minutes.
The primary driving force behind the inception
of the first Shinkansen was a humble engineer,
Hideo Shima, an employee of Japanese National
Railways, who was intensely passionate about
the future of trains and their core role
in public mass transit - he had a vision,
and fortunately his government listened. So,
you see, the Shinkansen was never just a train,
and it was never about speed, or world-leading
safety, or having shiny new toys to show off. It
was a symbol of Japan's resilience, innovation,
and vision. It was about saying - this is what’s
possible when government funds are put
into projects that make sense for and
directly benefit the people, rather than vanity
projects designed to win elections. Personally,
I think most countries can learn a lesson or
two from this humble electric train. Because
the ‘Bullet Train’ well and truly shot
Japan into the 21st century and beyond.